[Music]
you
holy crap youtubers they're dropping all
kinds of DC stuff this weekend they're
trying to own the next couple days Marv
will actually drop some guardians of the
galaxy stuff the minute they started
posting this so you see this nice war
going between the studios so the fallout
is that we're just gonna get a whole
bunch of awesome stuff so I'll be doing
a whole bunch of videos be sure to
subscribe to get them all there's even
an injustice to giveaway going on that
I'll explain at the end of the video but
the big deal is the reason they're
releasing the big Justice League trailer
this weekend and not saving it for
WonderCon in two weeks is because it's
the one-year anniversary of Batman V
Superman coming out so they're releasing
these one-shot teasers for each of the
characters but you notice there's no
cyborg teaser there's no Wonder Woman
teaser so because there's only like one
more day before they actually drop the
trailer they'll either drop nothing
tomorrow or they'll drop like a flash
teaser or a cyborg teaser but because
the Wonder Woman movie is coming out and
they're already posting so many trailers
for that I don't think they need to post
any Wonder Woman Justice League teasers
but the cool thing about these is that
they sort of reveal a big action set
piece for each of the characters Batman
fighting parademons in the upgraded
Batmobile so you don't get a good look
at it here but this is a high-res shot
of what the Batmobile upgrades look like
so in addition to the tactical suit the
Batmobile is just made to be more badass
because these parademons look almost
exactly like the ones that we saw during
Batman V Superman so you always wonder
when he saw those was he just
hallucinating something that his mind
came up with or was he being sent an
actual vision of what would come to pass
they called that the nightmare sequence
as in The Dark Knight
so at these parademons are the same as
those parademons it just implies that
when the flash came back in time he just
gave him an actual vision like a
snapshot of what would actually be
happening so the timeline of that is
still a little fuzzy because we're
seeing what happens after dark side
comes to earth it just completely lays
waste to everything the sons of Superman
are also a bit of a question too because
when we originally saw Batman vs
Superman the way I took that is that
he's just worried this Superman is going
to turn into a tyrant he'll have his own
set of followers worshipping him as a
god
but if this is an actual vision of the
future in Darkseid has already come to
earth that's what the Omega symbol is
all about that's how you know Darkseid
is victorious then this vision is so
much bigger
in just a manifestation of Batman's
fears about Superman so even though
we're only seeing it from Batman's
perspective in thinking about it through
a Superman lens like oh we got to stop
Superman because he's as crazy tyrant
there's this added layer that implies
that Darkseid has come to earth looking
for the mother boxes and all trees the
updated synopsis - because it says a
little bit about what's going on with
the plot of the movie that a version of
this will end up happening no matter
what but part of the whole point of this
sequence in addition to just giving you
a heart attack while you're sitting in
the theater like holy crap this is the
darkest timeline why is Superman so
angry why are parademons working for him
why does this look like injustice was
just a let Batman know that something's
coming over in the Marvel Universe the
same thing happened to Iron Man during
Avengers age of Ultron when the mind gem
or Scarlet Witch using the powers of the
mind gem gave him the vision that we
actually seen all the posters here this
is actually a sanctuary the place where
they're standing here in this green
screen if you guys didn't know so it's
almost like they're making this come
true the same thing will also probably
happen during Justice League you'll see
a version of this play out but it'll be
very different because Batman listened
to the flash and brought the Justice
League together this is the actual new
synopsis so it just reads in the wake of
Clark Kent
Superman's death at the hands of
doomsday in BBS vigilante Bruce
wayne/batman re-evaluates his extreme
methods and begins reaching out to
extraordinary heroes to assemble a team
of crime fighters to defend the earth
from all kinds of threats together with
Diana Prince Wonder Woman Batman seeks
out cybernetically enhanced former
college football star Vic stone cyborg
speedster Barry Allen the flash in
Atlantean warrior King Arthur curry
Aquaman
so that almost confirms that he's king
of Atlantis when the movie picks up but
continuing they faced off against
Steppenwolf The Herald and second in
command to alien warlord Darkseid who is
charged by Darkseid with hunting down
three artifacts hidden on earth so the
artifacts that he's referring to are the
mother boxes in the interesting thing is
that just like vision has the mind stone
in his forehead cyborg is now one of the
mother boxes so that's kind of bad news
for him but what about that Aquaman
teaser it says unite the seven a lot of
people including me took this to meet
unite the seven seas because that was a
big theme during aqua
as new 52 title I talk about that a
little bit in the Aquaman videos that
I've done so odd links for that at the
end of this but clearly in this context
they're talking about uniting the seven
members of the Justice League so who do
you ask is that seventh member well
we'll start with the sixth member
because there's no Superman in all this
so there are only five people initially
for what seems like a good portion of
the film but obviously we have confirmed
Superman in the film it wouldn't be
Justice League without Superman so
you're not gonna leave him in the coffin
on the bench but the seventh member is
Green Lantern they've already confirmed
that there'll be some form of Green
Lantern in the movie they just haven't
said which version and this is actually
really cool
the current rumor right now is that it
is a nonhuman Green Lantern with a
really weird name so there are a lot of
Green Lantern's with really weird names
but I think that they would go with a
really cool character that's a big name
in the Green Lantern comics but that
isn't one of the main ones from earth
like Hal Jordan Green Lantern Guy
Gardner so let me know in the comments
who do you think the mystery Green
Lantern is going to be I think odds are
it's Kilowog or tomar Rey because the
thing is it sounds like they're not
going to be doing a direct Green Lantern
origin where we are in the timeline
right now because the Green Lantern
Corps movie that's going to be coming
out in another three years or so around
2020 or so is supposed to be like lethal
weapon with an older Hal Jordan in a
younger Jon Stewart so Hal Jordan will
have been the Green Lantern for a long
time but if it's an older Hal Jordan
then they would probably spend more time
in that movie focusing on the origin of
the Jon Stewart Green Lantern but that's
a completely separate thing it's gonna
be a couple years down the road don't
have to worry about it now and the other
big thing a lot of you were asking me
about this was Aquaman's gear he has his
Trident and his full suit of armor so
that raises a lot of questions and the
fact that Batman's just sort of chucks
him his Trident like it's no big deal a
lot of you were asking if it's a Thor's
hammer situation if only Aquaman or
other Atlanteans are capable of wielding
it so it seems like that's not the case
like other people can touch it but I
would be willing to bet that Batman
doesn't know how to wield it only
Aquaman mera ocean masters someone from
Atlantis would be able to use it for its
full potential but the thing that we may
have overlooked here is that because he
actually has it it might mean that he's
already king of Atlantis when we meet
him in the movie because the Trident of
Neptune isn't just something that they
pass around that
almost like the king sword something
that the ruler of Atlantis holds if you
saw the animated movie throne of
Atlantis ocean master organizes a coup
against Atlantis and takes the trident
uses it to lead an all-out assault on
the surface we will cleanse the surface
soon they shall know that our time has
come I will bring our world
so the Trident itself is actually forged
from Neptune's essence remember there
are gods in this world because of the
Amazons that's sort of the intro to the
more mystical godlike realm of the DC
Universe so if Zeus exists then Neptune
exists or I guess you could say Poseidon
depending on which pantheon you're
talking about but the training itself
forged from his essence you can use it
to throw lightning create water to stand
on create giant storms transmute essence
I would say it's almost as powerful as
Thor's hammer probably more powerful
within its own environment within an
aquatic environment but he can't use it
to fly what's gonna happen next is a lot
of you been requesting a Legion video if
there's anything special you want me to
talk about for Justice League let me
know but I am expecting some more
Justice League footage tomorrow there's
also some Star Wars stuff that just
dropped so I'm gonna try and do video
for that too so depending on when new
footage drops I'll just post video
updates on the schedule as I go along
but congratulations to the latest
injustice giveaway winner Yogendra
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details it's just a pre-order
for the game because it hasn't been
released yet so there was a new round
that started in this video I'm just
gonna keep that going because there's so
much Justice League footage that's gonna
be dropping in the next couple days
while you wait for that to post you can
click here for new flash and you can
click here for that Aquaman
test footage thank you so much for
watching let's high five I'll see you
guys in the next video
you